- Good morning, Hank. It's Tuesday.
- Huhhhhhhhh.
- Oh, it's some kind of reunion video.
- Hi.
- Okay, this is a very special edition
of Question Tuesday in which I ask you questions
that contain the word first.
- Just like the first comment does.
- That's actually my first question.
How do you feel about people writing "first"
in the comments of YouTube videos?
- It used to bother me, John.
- It doesn't bother me.
In fact, every time I am first--
- Yeah, right.
- I can't stop myself.
- Right, it used to bother me until I was like,
until I was first on a video
and I was like, (whispers) I have to--
I want to do this.
- Hank, do you remember the first movie
that made you cry?
- American Tail.
- I think it was American Tail.
Hank, what are your best first aid tips?
(both laugh)
- Call a doctor.
- No! No!
Apply pressure to the wound!
- What if there's no wound?
Just apply pressure.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Pressure, pressure.
- That's-- I can confirm that's unpleasant.
Do not touch the couch under any circumstances.
(Hank laughs)
This is an incredibly delicate setup
we've got, and it's not particularly straight.
Hank, what was the first book you fell in love with?
- Uh, (laughs) Jurassic Park.
- Really?
- Yeah.
(John grunts in disgust)
Possibly the sequel.
- The Lost World?
- Yeah.
- Wow.
(Hank laughs)
Really?
- I loved it so much.
- Oh.
For me, it was Gus is a Bug.
What was your first broken bone?
- I think one of these.
- Incorrect!
- Oh you remember?
- I do.
- What was it?
- You fell out of a tree house,
and you broke your arm.
- No, I did not.
- You did.
- I did not.
-You definitely did.
- Call Mom.
- Okay.
- Did I ever fall out of a tree, Mom?
Do you ever remember me breaking a bone--
- A tree house!
- falling out of a tree?
- A tree house.
- [Mom] No.
(John groans)
- [Mom] John fell out of a tree house.
- Who did?
- [Mom] John.
- Oh!
- You fell out of a tree house?
- It's a memory of myself.
(Hank and Mom laugh)
- Funny how brains work.
- Hank, what was your first concert?
- I think it was probably They Might Be Giants.
- I think it was They Might Be Giants. I remember it.
You were young. You were like 11.
- Okay, you were there?
- Yeah.
- My first concert may have been the B-52s
now that I'm thinking about it.
- I think the B-52s opened for the Violent--
- [Both] The Violent Femmes opened for the B-52s.
- Hank, do you remember the first time you saw snow fall?
- I remember the first time I saw snow
on the ground in Alabama.
And I was like there it is! It's a thing!
- The first time I saw snow fall,
I was fully like 9 or 10 years old,
and I was astonished,
because I thought snowflakes were like the ones
that you make in elementary school--
- Like cut out?
Yeah.
- I thought they were about that big.
- I thought they were made up.
(John laughs)
I thought they were a made-up idea,
and then I saw a snowflake,
and I was like, it's the shape!
- Yeah.
I thought that about moonlight.
I thought that--
- I also thought that about--
this is weird, because we live in like street light central,
and so, like the first time you have a shadow
cast by the moon, you're like, what?
What's casting that shadow?
- I was like, does this mean I'm a werewolf?
I thought moonlight was like,
I don't know, like passenger pigeons,
like something that had a time that had passed.
(Hank laughs)
- It was just over somehow?
- Yeah.
Hank, do you remember your first tweet?
Don't worry, I already wrote it down
in case you don't remember.
- It was probably like, I'm starting up Twitter now,
let's see how that goes.
- No, that was my first tweet.
(both laugh)
Your first tweet was in June of 2007
back on your Ecogeek handle--
- Oh!
- and it was, "Writing up some stories for Ecogeek.
Wondering when Google will buy Twitter."
- Oh, if only they had.
- Yeah, I mean it still kind of makes sense.
- But Google has such a successful
existing social network in Google+.
Hank, when was the last time
you did something for the first time?
- It's the first time I've had all of these cells.
It's the first time that
I've probably ever worn this outfit.
- Do you know the last time
you'll do something for the first time?
- Ai yi yi.
- (whispers) Death.
Okay, Hank, DFTBA. I will see you...
- Right now.
- I'll continue to see you.
- Yeah.